so this is basically what I did with
that year 10 cohort if you're wondering
how they got to that stage in five weeks
I'm going to whisk through this because
you guys should understand it very
quickly so this is actually ancient mine
the ancient Mayans actually came up with
the concept of zero roughly the same
time as the Hindus but it's forgotten
about for some reason but their concept
of zero it was called mix bowl and they
thought of zero not as nothingness but
actually is the seed of all other
numbers and that's what makes but
apparently means in action mine but I
don't know whether anyone speaks ancient
mind here and so these were the symbols
obviously it's Vanessa mall which is
placed 20 they needed 20 symbols and
you'll probably recognize these they're
pretty obvious obviously they didn't
have matchsticks in those days I think
they were just sticks and beans and a
shell and after nine we moved on to 10
which is two sticks and so on and so on
two sticks and four beings up to 19 and
of course 0 2 19 is 20 simple so now
we've run out of symbols so how do they
represent 20 anyone like that okay so
they had a 1 in the 20s column that it
wasn't the column it was a a row or a
box and 0 in the units and then they
started again and so what's this number
okay it's yep you're right and I would
probably call it 60 10 yeah 3 20 60 and
ten units no obviously that's 70 in base
10 they probably I don't know typically
in vases you you'd call it you know and
or three to 10 or something cool so
there we go Oh what about
yeah good good i have heard a comforting
by the way you know i'm saying what
about that one I'm looking at you all
and this is how your students feel
you're in a classroom full of maths
teachers and can you imagine anything
more embarrassing than getting the
answer so yeah this is an 520 s which
217 217 what was interesting about this
was that it was almost like um what you
call it experimental archaeology that
one of the kids said oh well ever stick
in that box means a hundred and I
haven't really thought about that and
and that's absolutely right that and
maybe that's what they thought every
stick in that box is 100 rather than
five twenties so that's pretty cool
isn't it we might have rediscovered how
the ancient Mayans thought about number
and okay what about this one anyone in
your head okay
you want to say go gone gives it
yeah that's 100 that's one in the what
is 400 scholar column yep because is 20
squared and five in the a thousands
column so yeah well done so that's 58
thousands 1 405 20s and 11 units
otherwise I mean are you never you could
did that in your head I suppose 40,000
511 cool it's Sunday and how about that
that's quite a profound question anyone
who really understands number basis
should have their arm straight up in the
air brilliant well done 19 and 19 can
you explain why which is absolutely
brilliant mathematical elegance it's one
less than 400 because you felt oh sorry
it's that's how you do it it's got to be
one less than 400 so it's one less than
100 so these two columns or rows or
whatever have to be full in the same way
as 99 known as the maximum symbol in
base 10 so that's one less than 400 and
you can just verify yes it's 399 and
friend of mine and David Horton who some
of you know had a lovely way of thinking
about that which in fact i'll just show
you this one so what do you think this
number is brilliant and isn't that
wonderful someone just got all 7999 whoa
are you a computing genius no it's one
less neck hasn't it's nice a nice
did I do something wrong oh oops I
thought was well prepared for this that
cheddar I'm not and second so anyway um
yeah David Horton he gave us analogy
said it's like one of those mechanical
counters that you click click click
click click and the wheel turns wheel
turns freak number and it turns in the
unit Colin and there's a little pin
connected so that when it gets up to
nine it flips over the next column along
and you get one of the 10 is increasing
and then when it gets in 99 the two pins
flip over and then one in the hundreds
and this is the same but with 19 digits
on each wheel which is quite a nice way
of thinking about it and and then after
we don't ancient mine they were pretty
proud of themselves because they could
actually count in ancient myself you do
realize that's completely and utterly
useless in life because all the mines
died out long ago and they were so
thrilled um so they'd learned something
really academic and useless so best 10 I
mean I'm not going to go through this
you should understand it quite well by
now that's what best 10 looks like but
it yeah and then other number basis so
numb by seven we've got seven symbols 0
to 60 and represents seven what do you
think 10 good and and of course they say
10 a lot and you have said no it isn't
10 it's seven that is 717 not 110 so
it's 10 that's a better way of saying it
and and then this is the counting in Bay
7 up to six it's same as base 10 then it
goes 10 11 12 13 14 15 16 and 20 21 22
23 and so on until you get to you know
36 is 27 because it's three sevens which
is 21 and 6 units page seven um you see
what this is doing in a way this is a
giving a little profound understanding
of place position rather than just a
superficial one in base 10 it's also
introducing indices and in 7th power 0
you know and everything to pass 0 and if
you really want you can go this way and
go 7 to the power minus 1 what does that
mean and it's a seventh and seven to the
power minus 2 49 that can be done really
you're a cup if they're in stands um so
here's base 3 it just has three digits
and three symbols so 10 now means three
and those three counting looks like this
I'm going quickly because I'm aware of
the fact otherwise I want to get to the
end of my show and I'm sort of
absolutely bang-on it man so look 1000
no it isn't it's 127 it's one in the
27th corn so to 22 is the equipment of
999 in base 10 22 22 in the 9s column 3
squared squat to in the 3s column and
two in the unit's column so that it's
not 18 plus six plus one that you view
20 plus 2 sorry if I go to 26 I'm going
cryptic but you have got the notes and
so base to so so that was best three
columns face too and how useful is based
to I mean the answer is very because we
will use it in computers and everything
but not many people actually understand
what bitten by a 6832 bit and 64bit mean
or why 32-bit operating systems can
address more than four gig of ram or
stuff like that but actually it's very
easy to explain if you understand base
to so base 2 oops doesn't look like that
that's a student looking at a tree and
best to looks like that and now to the
power 8 is 256 which is a sort of number
that you can and
and one bite is actually an 8-bit so
each one of these is called a bit and
binary digit bit and and it just is on
or off 1 or 0 5 volts or 0 in
electronics and Oren CMOS is 15 volts a
month 15 volts or something like that
and so so that if you put these switches
together if you put eight of them
together you can represent up to 255 if
all of these were ones it would be one
less than 250 56 so 0 to 255 so you can
represent 2 to the 8 or 256 different
state and that's how computers in code
writing if you type a letter in on the
keyboard every letter you type or
Spacewar funny character that gets
encoded with some called ascii code
which is a lookup table of values so for
example little a i think is remember 96
or something and it's actually a 1 1 1
10000 whatever that is 64 plus 32 get 96
m and so you just have a look up table
so you can represent a letter a
character with one bite and if you want
to know how many bytes you need not
using microsoft word but using just a
text and thing and you just need to
multiply the number of characters by
well that's how many but you need to
storage and and then 32 bit operating
system has 30 bit 32-bit words so it can
represent numbers up to I don't know
16-bit 65536 which is tooth / 16 to 32
is something like four billion yeah four
gig and that's why you can't address
more than that in a 32-bit operating
system interesting huh